José está entrenando para un concurso de
comer hot dogs.
La persona que coma más hot dogs en 10 minutos
será el ganador.
Si "r" es el número de hot dogs que José
puede comer en un minuto
y "n" es el número total de hot dogs que él come en el concurso, podemos escribir la siguiente ecuación,
si "n" es el número de hot dogs que come
en el concurso y lo dividimos entre 10 minutos
que es lo que dura el concurso, esto nos va
a dar "r", el número de hot dogs que en promedio,
José come en un minuto.
Si José puede comer 6 4/5 hot dogs en un minuto, aquí nos están dando el valor de "r",
¿cuántos hot dogs puede comer
durante los 10 minutos del concurso?
Es decir, nos están pidiendo el valor de
"n" que tenemos aquí.
Así es que "n" dividido entre 10 es el valor de "r",
que es 6 4/5 el número de hot dogs
que puede comer por minuto.
Hay dos maneras de atacar esto, una manera
es, bueno, si tenemos que este es el número
de hot dogs que puede comer por minuto y el
concurso dura 10 minutos, pues multiplicamos
por 10 este número, entonces en 10 minutos
él puede comer 6 por 10 = 60 y 4/5 por 10 = 8,
él podría comer 68 hot dogs,
básicamente estamos multiplicando por 10 ambos lados de la ecuación.
Otra manera de resolver esto es probar los
números, va a tomar más tiempo pero nos
da una idea de cómo se relacionan los números
a través de esta ecuación.
Sobretodo que aquí nos están dando una serie
de números con los cuales podemos probar.
Por supuesto, la mejor opción es trabajar
lógicamente esto para encontrar el número
que si dividimos entre 10 nos da 6 4/5 y así
encontrar como lo hemos hecho que el número
es 68 ó si lo prefieres, puedes probar estos
distintos números,
65 dividido entre 10 es 6.5, ese no es el
valor de "r" que tenemos.
56 dividido entre 10 es 5.6 que tampoco corresponde.
68 dividido entre 10 es 6.8 ó 6 8/10
que simplificando es 6 4/5,
así encontraríamos este valor de 68.
Y finalmente probamos 45 dividido entre 10
es 4.5, que no corresponde al valor de "r".
En fin, ambos métodos son válidos, lo importante
aquí es que entiendas cómo funciona esta
relación y cómo es que interactúan estas variables.